tell about 550 million years ago life on
Earth is pretty simple and then suddenly
in geologically speaking in a very short
period of time we see a huge explosion
of body plans and types of animal
appearing and lots of bizarre forms that
are so different from modern animal life
that are very hard to interpreting to
recognize so we're here now in the
sedgwick Museum of Earth Sciences in
Cambridge and we've walked all the way
to the end of the museum to look at the
earliest complex animal fossils and when
we look at these fossils we find a whole
array of very unusual and weird things
and one of the weirdest I think has to
be Hallucigenia which is named for its
dreamlike appearance and scientists have
found very difficult to know exactly
what to do with this unusual spiny work
so we noticed that it had pairs of
really stiff spines running along one
side of the organism and long flexible
appendages on its other side and when
this was described in the 1970s it was
reinterpreted walking on these long
stiff spines as if walking along pairs
of stilts and using these flexible
appendages that would have been on its
back to press food along the body to its
enormous balloon shaped head this is
he's quite a weird reconstruction a very
bizarre animal and not something that we
have any modern analogue for today
so more recently researchers thought
well let's go back to Hallucigenia and
they've got a dental drill and chipped
away at the mud and found hidden
underneath the rock a second half of the
pair of legs so the original idea of
Hallucigenia was completely the wrong
way up polluted genius suddenly looks a
little bit more normal but still not the
kind of thing you'd expect to find
floating around in aquaria so Luther
Genie has got a long and checkered
history of reinterpretation and even 100
years after it was first discovered
there's still a lot that we didn't
understand which end with its head which
end with its tail so to try and shed a
bit more light on this perpetually
elusive organism we tried put it into an
electron microscope to see what new
observations we might be able
so there most of the work on the
original specimens between the Royal
Ontario Museum in Toronto but I do have
a couple of casts of material upstairs
so what we have here is a cast of one of
the Hallucigenia fossils that I've been
studying and you can see it's much
smaller than you might expect it's maybe
a centimeter long a millimeter across
and you can just make out its little
spines its legs and its body London on
the middle before our study we knew
which way up Hallucigenia also we knew
had legs on the bottom spines on the top
we didn't really know which em was its
head in which time was its tail and
there was still this idea that there was
this balloon shaped head at one end and
actually when we look every at the
fossils we realized that this wasn't a
head this wasn't part of the animal but
it was stained representing decay fluids
that had been squeezed out of one end of
the gut available during the
fossilization and burial process so in
fact we were looking at the tail end of
the organism not the head and the head
was to be found at the other side when
we put them in the microscope we moved
over towards one ends where we thought
the head might be hoping to find a pair
of eyes and when we got to the head we
saw not just a pair of eyes but there
was this almighty grin underneath them
it's large sort of semicircular smile
that we just hadn't been expecting at
all with the new description we can
imagine Hallucigenia
looking a bit like a caterpillar but
with really long flimsy extensible legs
and these pairs of conical spines
running along its back so it sort of
looks like a twig with loads of sticks
coming out of it all the way along
I think the thing I love about
Hallucigenia is how it's so good at
keeping secrets and revealing them one
at a time there's there's so much that
it's revealed over the time and each
time you think okay we kind of getting a
hang of it there's another surprise up
its sleeve someone